I can't make I can't make heads or tails
of George papadopolis literally if I was
strong enough to pick him up and flip
him over in the air I don't know if he
would land head up her head down I have
no idea why would you do that
[Applause]
of course we've all been monitoring
Hurricane Florence our thoughts are with
everyone affected tonight's show we hope
offers some temporary relief for our
viewers as we spend an hour on less
important stuff we don't pretend
politics and gossip mean more than this
storm so let's pause for a moment and
consider other natural disasters don't
even have to say more you know politics
is like sex with Michael Moore you're
either on top or you're crushed like the
broken stars on Hollywood Boulevard
which is officially a disaster area so
how bad is it getting there well the
left is turning on the left case in
point
Debra Messing lashed out at fellow lefty
Susan Sarandon why oh my god Susan said
that Donald Trump has inspired more
women and minorities to run for office
so Deb gets on Twitter and she says all
this means stuff like STFU which I
believe stands for still tweeting
forever uninformed now in case you
forgot who Debbie is she's the star of
an old TV comedy that they brought back
just like Obama but thanks to trump and
her new life on twitter she has gone
from this okay she doesn't have the
stomach to go where I go mmm to this
what is it
now
talk about a fall from grace but just to
prove playing a smart funny woman was
all an act she now loses her regularly
on Twitter over Trump yes the star of a
20 year old sitcom is now still coming
to terms with an election that's two
years old it must seem like yesterday to
her as she seems to us in fact but
that's the issue with celebs nobody in
America is wearing a bracelet that says
what would Hollywood do and that hurts
they can't believe no one takes them
seriously when all they do is take
themselves seriously as they attack
everyone else it's my theory celebrities
come to politics later in life after
devoting four decades
selfishly chasing attention they think
that because they get to spend 22
minutes in the spotlight once a week
pretending to be relevant they also
deserve real-life importance so they
take a big stupid bite out of politics
the wild success they had in that drama
class
sophomore year parroting other people's
words is still what keeps them going
which is why Hollywood's greatest
political theorists messing DeNiro Penn
they all have the mentality of emotional
seventeen-year-olds and what defines
troubled youth at that age irrational
anger petulant rage demands for
attention and without a better script
their emotional response is inversely
proportional to their knowledge and
wisdom so the less that they know the
stronger they feel and so belief becomes
a battle to them and if you disagree you
are evil but you can't improvise
intelligence which is why it's funny
when they go off script
you can't just demonize that will and
then play Grace
[Music]
actors
actors actors will say and do anything
for a spotlight here's Broadway legend
Carol cook revealing her knowledge of
American history where is John Wilkes
Booth when you need right
will I be on an enemies list so that's
what happened to the ropers finally
[Applause]
people remember Three's Company I was
worried about that joke anyway once you
go down this rabbit hole of insanity
there's no going back you start turning
on anyone and everyone including the
Liberals on your side of course we all
know these people are self indulgent and
crazy so nobody takes them seriously the
crazy here these people become the
closer they come to bad comedy meaning
MSNBC ladies and gentlemen the last
President of the United States you think
that last president United States it's
possible you really think that I think
it's possible absolutely
you ever notice you ever notice about
Michael Moore that he's slowly morphing
into Large Marge from pee-wee's big
adventure you know I'd say get rid of
the Hat but that's where he hides the
emergency Twinkies
so we'll Trump you the last president of
the United States is the world actually
ending now as normal people like you
watch hurricane coverage with mass
evacuations and ninety mile per hour
gusts and beyond heavy rain we can only
see how disconnected Hollywood is
fighting a 20-foot reality surge their
world is storming and Manta fort no
wonder their self-importance their
sanity their perspective their politics
are truly all wet and Gone with the Wind